little piece about discipline i did have
a routine a routine that was instilled
into me by colonel sink
at koa colonel sink insisted that
officers always shave in the morning
regardless of the situation he would say
you shave every morning for the troops
and if you want to shave every evening
for the women that's up to you i
followed his orders because i realized
that i
had to set the proper example for the
men
i needed to get their attention let them
all know that i intended to be around
for a while
and that the situation was not as bad as
they might think
i remember before second battalion
attacked foy i had awakened early and
shaved before i ate breakfast
i later discovered that i'd cut my face
in multiple places
when colonel sink came up to check on
the battalion's readiness before the
attack commenced
he took one look at me and smiled i
realized that he was laughing at me for
shaving on that bitterly cold morning
in hindsight shaving at zero dark 30 and
freezing temperatures was pretty
ridiculous
i so you know we talk about this all the
time gotta shave gotta
maintain unmitigated daily discipline
and all things
but what's cool that what i the reason i
wanted to go over this again is because
look at what he's doing psychologically
to the troops
he's saying i know i had to set an
example i needed to get their attention
and make them realize like hey we're
going to be here for a while and you
know what i'm just going to go
daily this is no big deal oh you're
worried about this stuff i'm still
shaving over here
i'm still waking up at 0-400 shaving and
and you're worried about this stuff
nothing worried about
we're good to go and you need to
maintain the same discipline
so that leading by example clearly
is a big deal right there and
maintaining that routine
maintaining that discipline now speaking
of discipline back to the book
regardless of how disciplined an outfit
is too much time on your hands too
little activity and too much alcohol
make a volatile combination so
this book skips around a little bit but
i put this in here because this is this
is actually talking about when they were
done fighting
and now everyone was kind of idle he has
some idol people on their hands but it
related to discipline so i wanted to
lock it in a little bit back to the book
the battalion was no longer a combat
unit
but a garrison outfit it was more
important to keep the troops gainfully
employed to prevent boredom
and monotony that would lead to a
breakdown and discipline and when that
occurs
soldiers get careless consequently the
first thing we organized
were calisthenics and athletic programs
you know i always joke about you know
when people say they have some kind of
problem and i'm like oh
do burpees right hey you know what a
good solution to all problems are
calisthenics
just start doing calisthenics i like
that i like that attitude
i vividly recall this is this is another
reason why i put this in
i vividly recall watching the men
stripped to their waist or only wearing
their shorts
as they played baseball the sight of all
those scars
made me conscious of the fact that only
a handful of men in the battalion had
been lucky enough to make it through all
four campaigns
without at least one scar some men had
two three or even four scars on their
chest back arms or legs
keep in mind that this was after the war
so i was looking only at men
who were not seriously wounded next we
set up rifle ranges
and sharpened our marksmanship close
order drill
and troop reviews were once again back
on the training schedule
i also established a schedule where each
of our four platoons
could rotate every 72 hours to a ski
lodge in the alps
for rest and relaxation the purpose of
using this retreat was to let the men
get away from
the routine of a military schedule
so first of all when i got the seal team
one and actually was it wasn't when i
first got there but there was a
master chief at seal team one that had
showed up in
1971 or 1972 to seal team one
and seal team one you know you had 150
guys
roughly on the team at that time and
they had had
34 killed in action in vietnam at seal
team one
and wounded was i don't know how many
wounded but it was a lot but this
this guy who was a master chief when i
met him and he was telling me that when
he
you know at the seal team you would you
know you pt in the morning just like a
sports team you get you get to work and
you work out
and here's he's a new guy right and he's
they they pt
and then they go in the shower you know
to to wash off and
it's the same thing he's like looking at
every single guy's scarred up wounded
you know slashes on their chest bullet
holes in them
and he kind of was saying to himself
damn
you know this is uh this has been trial
by fire for these guys
but beyond that what he's talking about
here
clearly is if you
and i'll tell you this especially with
you know 18 year old 19 year old 20 year
old
males that have joined the military if
you don't find something for them to do
productive
they're going to find something to do
that's not going to be productive it'll
be fun for them
it'll be fun for them they're going to
have a good time but it's not
there's a chance that they could be
doing something better than what you're
letting them do
now of course he talks about the fact
that he's given still giving them time
to go out to the ski lodge and
and break away from it a little bit but
you just got to be careful on how you do
that
you got to be careful on how you do that
it's
it can backfire if you're not careful
and
the first time i was ever kind of
detached from a seal platoon on a it was
when i went to training
the training department at seal team one
what we used to call
training cell which sounds legit
and it was legit so at training cell
the first trip i went on with a platoon
because i was always in the platoon
so the first trip i went on with the
platoon
and i was outside of the platoon and i
was
you you could say i was an instructor
even though we weren't running around
calling ourselves instructor
instructors we would call ourselves
actually the cadre i don't know why
it's just like oh yeah cadre sounds
still
yeah the training cadre so when we were
at training cell
because the instructors are kind of
considered the buds instructors the guys
are at the basic training
and we didn't really want to be buds
instructors we were the cadres
hell yeah so and i never i didn't mean
this is just this is just my own
assessment i didn't make up cadre i
didn't call ourselves cadre i didn't
make a training cell i wish i would have
made up all those things but i just
flowed into him as a lucky young new guy
and actually at this point i wasn't a
new guy anymore wait but it's true
though right it's not like
you just gave yourself a title that
wasn't no no we were the cop yeah yeah
oh training cadre yeah yeah oh hey i
need to talk to you guys in the cadre
over here yeah that's
what we called ourselves right oh yeah
so it's like you know like let's say you
open a jiu jitsu gym
and then you know you're teaching people
and then you're like okay yeah i'm i'm
the instructor
and then you say you know what i like
professor that's better yeah no wasn't
that
it's not that i didn't make that no no
no they called you know
for years and actually i think roger
hayden talked about it
when he was on the podcast he was
talking about when he was cadre so right
it's been around forever right that's
why just like professor it's like it's
true
you are the professor but it's like it
just sounds it's just better you know it
sounds better so i'm gonna go ahead and
go with that one
just go with cadre yeah i like that i
don't even know
what i was talking about oh so i was i
was in the cadre for the first time
and we went on a trip we went to a trip
where they have
good times to be had where we were it
was it was a place where there's some
good training but there's also good
times and you know i picked this up from
harley flanagan
this term which i hadn't really heard
wilding did you hear him say that
he's like oh we were just wilding yeah
which i think is a better
term than the term that we discussed
which was partying right right oh
there's good
yeah we were partying yeah i like
wilding better because that entails all
kinds of other things a little bit more
wild yeah a little bit more wild yeah
wilding out or what's this
i never really heard i never really
heard it before he's but when harley
said i mean clearly you know what it is
yeah
yeah and it's in his book too he talks
about wilding
so we went to this place with a seal
platoon where there was
good training and good wilding to be had
and i remember the first time that these
guys you know we get their rework a
little bit and then they're gonna go out
in into the town and i remember thinking
myself they've been in the field for a
few days
and they were all fired up young
frog man and i was thinking myself how
is this even gonna work like there's no
there's no possibility of this going
well then it did you know everyone fine
but you just see all these guys
they're ready to you know they're ready
to explode and you're gonna they've been
in the field
they've dehydrated they've been in the
field for four days or five days they're
all dehydrated
and they completed their operation they
feel good about it now you're going to
let them out in town and it's
yeah you got to be careful in those
scenarios you got to put something
yeah we we would you know sometimes you
just say hey look yeah do whatever you
want tonight but we're pt
tomorrow at zero 700. so then everyone
knows they can
make it wild to a point but they can't
yeah
they got to put some kind of a governor
some kind of a governor on the scenario